what's in a name  well that depends on what you do with it  put it out there leveled it up get good  with it like really good get it voted  for get it fear get it to the top of the  ladder  if you got what it takes test it at the  combine sign it on a contract get it on  a team get it in a tournament get it on  a big monthly check cash it commit to it  put it on everything what about this  thing and it's bigger than that make  your whole city note check that the  whole world here we talked about see it  in the headlines then watch it all come  crashing down  wait what okay  get it back on the map get it back on  top get it as the number one fantasy  draft pick bring it to the playoffs get  it on the back of a champion that's your  name  better yet become a champion hear it on  the lips of thousands of screaming fans  chanting it over and over and over again  why  well that's up to you  you